david chang is talking to us about his
struggles to overcome professional
and personal struggles that include much
more than the pandemic chang of course
is the celebrated chef
and restaurateur of 13 restaurants
around the world many
under the momofuku name he's also the
creator and host
of the dave chang show podcast and two
netflix shows including the food and
travel show
ugly delicious but in a deeply personal
new memoir
he talks about dealing with his
challenges and first on cbs this morning
he spoke to us
from his los angeles restaurant major
domo
it is a battle of survival that is as
clear as that
its survival is the word in this
industry what are we serving today
for chef david chang it's personal are
we doing pasta for two
the six time james beard award winner
has had to close
two of his restaurants and consolidate
two more
due to the pandemic you kind of like
being the underdog
i do because i get my juices flowing and
i get the best work done but this is
this is a very difficult obstacle
this crisis for the restaurant industry
comes as it's already confronting
me too allegations and it's notoriously
toxic work environment whether it's
workers rights benefits or abuse in a
kitchen
we need to have these conversations to
fix this
moving forward and i think before you
can sort of fix your culture and your
kitchen and your restaurants
you need to sort of work on yourself
first and
you know i've been a bully and i have
i have a temper and it's something i've
tried to address over the years
in his new memoir eda peach chang writes
i hate that the anger has become my
calling card
where did your temper come from the
funny thing is i don't think i really
had the temper
until i got into cooking i put so much
meaning in cooking
because it saved my life it gave me
purpose so
anyone that wound up not respecting it
or caring about something as much as i
did
meant that it was an attack on me and my
values
the child of north and south korean
immigrants
chang grew up in suburban virginia he
was a child
golf prodigy but always felt
uncomfortable
in school you didn't feel like you fit
in no i
i still have a hard time i've always
felt
you know in between in between what not
ever going to be part of white culture
and
never going to be part of korean
korean-american culture
but chang did feel at home in the
kitchen
his father disapproved of his career but
gave him a loan to launch his first
restaurant and that was his way of
expressing love
he was unable to say i love you chang's
idea
to open a japanese noodle shop in new
york city
in 2004 it was a huge gamble
you keep putting yourself in situations
where
part of you thinks you really could fail
you sound like my my psychiatrist too
it's like why do
i constantly put myself in situations
that are so precarious
every time i open a restaurant like
we're never doing this again and
you also say that opening a restaurant
is like heroin for you
it is cooking in general is like heroin
because you just get these dopamine hits
all the time this industry and how i do
my job
is 99 suffering in pain and misery
it's that one percent when things go
right that makes it all worthwhile
the beard award goes to david chang
momofuku was a breakout success but
chang had trouble
accepting the acclaim food and wine
called to
tell you that you were going to be one
of the best new chefs and you wanted to
decline
i did decline it and then dana cowan
said in 20 years of me doing this no
one's ever said no and you're not going
to be the first one
if you have low self-esteem and low
confidence and no one's ever told you
you're good
at anything and all of a sudden people
tell you you're good at something how
are you supposed to process that
the easiest way is to deflect it and say
it's not true and to put your head in
the sand and that's what i did
and i still do chang whose battle
depression
was close with food and travel icon
anthony bourdain
who died by suicide in 2018.
that must have really shaken you that
was hard
and still is hard when tony passed
um i think honestly that was one of the
reasons why
i decided to actually take this book on
in earnest
i was tired of being able to not talk
about this in public
chang now works with a therapist who
diagnosed him with bipolar disorder
i didn't realize that i was depressed in
high school or
or college until i actually got help
i just thought this is just me and
everything seems terrible and i'm sad
and i don't know why
i have these thoughts all i want people
to understand is
the hardest thing and the bravest thing
you can often do is just to say you need
help
his wife grace has been a big help
and now with son hugo to raise david
chang is trying to change
the future by being honest about his
past
being able to create a family with my
wife i'm learning there are more
important things than work
serious news what do you see when you
see hugo i want someone that
doesn't make the same mistakes i do i
just want to be the best father
i can my happiness is going to be the
systematic deprogramming of whoever the
hell
i think that i am and to be someone else
that i hope that i am
yeah what a great picture wow this book
is
all about david chang trying to
understand himself
and it's and it's fascinating because he
is just
blisteringly honest about everything i
mean he writes i feel a compulsion to
legitimize my depression
even now depression and the choice to
resist it are the only reasons you're
hearing from me here well i admire him
so much number one anthony that was a
great interview for david chang to open
up the way he did and people only do
that when they feel comfortable talking
to you so
bravo to you for that but when he said
the bravest thing you can do sometime
is to say you need help i remember
seeing he and grace out and about when
she was pregnant
and he was so happy about the baby
coming and hugo is adorable and
just imagine the kind of father he's now
going to be yeah oh i was a beautiful
piece
very touched by that and i i i'm sure he
wouldn't want me to say it but it seems
like he's becoming a beautiful person if
he never thought to himself
yeah i mean i think he's still wrestling
with all that stuff as you can see but
but but he but he's confronting it and
he does that in this book it's a great
read
david chang's new memoir eda peach is on
sale now wherever you buy your books
and hear more of our conversation with
david chang on today's cbs this morning
podcast